at the heart of it there's two things
that we look really really hard for I
mean there's there's kind of the surface
level stuff you look for so you look for
a huge market you look for you know
differentiating technology and you look
for you know incredible people I think
in practice I think that we collectively
and certain we specifically and then we
collectively VCS I think we probably we
spend a lot of time talking about
markets and technology and we have lots
of opinions and I'm not sure that those
opinions are actually all that relevant
all that often I think probably the
decision ultimately is and should be
around people as like 90% of the
decision the two things we really zero
in on a people are you know two things
they sound simple they end up being very
difficult courage and genius courage is
the one we talk about a lot because it's
the one that people can learn you know
courage courage which is to say not
giving up in the face of adversity you
know just being absolutely determined to
succeed you know is something that you
can you can like force yourself to do it
can be very painful you can force
yourself to do it
the genius part is a little bit hard to
force yourself to do you know courage
without genius might not get you where
you need to go but genius without
courage almost certainly won't and so
we're looking for some kind of magic
combination of genius and courage you
know there's there's a there's a one of
our one of my partner's you quotes
Nietzsche a lot on these stuff he says
it's it's it's a will its will to power
it's it's you know it's people who
simply will not stop and by the way
right there's always been this kind of
thing a Silicon Valley of like you know
sort of this I call it the failure
fetish right failure is good right
failure did you tell you guys are
probably all thought this heard about
this one a lot of people like failure is
a wonderful thing failure teaches you
all this stuff and it's great to fail a
lot like and we don't like buy any of
that we think that's all complete
complete nonsense we think failure sucks
we think failure is a terribly terribly
depressing thing to go through we think
success on the other hand is wonderful I
know you wouldn't think that this is
something you have to actually say out
loud but we do find it to be clarifying
when we point it out and so we are
strongly biased towards people who are
so determined to succeed that they just
they never give up they never quit
and I think that is a huge part of it
and that's something we really look deep
we look try to look deeply for it and
you know yeah that's the kind of thing
that's not listed on a resume right
that's something that has to be deep in
somebody's fundamentally deep in
somebody's character and you have to see
it in their backgrounds